[Music]
sad news out of our nation's capital
today California Senator Diane Feinstein
staff announced that she passed away
last night at the age of 90 by the way
our prayers Thoughts with the Senator's
family um let us be very blunt here
democrats should be ashamed of
themselves her obvious Health struggles
were readily apparent with anybody to
eyes with eyes to see for many many
months now earlier this year she missed
nearly what 3 months battling shingles
when asked about her absence you may
recall shortly after returning to the
hill uh I've been here working she had
no recollection during a during a testy
exchange with reporters not a good
moment her staff was shielding her from
the media you might recall for example
you know the time that we had uh
literally had somebody in her ear saying
when she was called upon given a speech
rather than just voting just say I just
say I okay she was not up to the job at
that point and prominent Democrats
across the country just simply refused
to do what was in her best interest let
her retire in dignity why that's
politics and you know what it's kind of
heartless and uh in many ways you could
even argue soulless here with reaction
Fox News contributor Tammy Bruce Fox do
his medical contributor Dr Nicole
Sapphire Dr Nicole those those two
moments alone when you know when she
didn't remember that she hadn't been
there for 3 months I I've been here the
whole time no she wasn't there the whole
time or you know being called upon uh
and having to have an aid whisper just
say I uh
basically it's it's so embarrassing for
her she had a distinguished career many
many decades and to not put her health
and her best interest at heart and her
Legacy because people sadly will
remember a lot of the the last days not
the not the good times and the year
dedicated years of service that's sad to
me well Sean Senator Feinstein has been
a force when it came to breast cancer
legislation introducing the pals act
working with breast density legislation
a lot of things that I deal with she has
ensured that young women have access to
screening mammograms and other screening
modalities but unfortunately as you're
pointing out right now she is not
necessarily going to be remembered for
her impact that she had through her seat
in the Senate you know we have to
acknowledge that she did re you know
break through that glass ceiling by
living to the age of 90 90 that far
exceeded the US life expectancy for a
woman which is about 80 years old in
fact less than 5% of us women make it to
the age of 90 but throughout the course
of this last year before then all we
knew that is she had a pacemaker placed
at the age of 83 she didn't really have
any major medical issues but over the
course of the last year she had viral
incilius Ramsey Hunt syndrome and then
we've seen a slow deterioration of her
physical health and probably cognitive
health health as well she even suffered
a fall late this summer and as you're
pointing out yes it is very obvious that
she was deteriorating and it is sad that
at this point throughout the last year
this is how people are going to NE are
going to remember her by she should have
been in retirement she should have been
enjoying the last days at home with her
friends and family yet they were still
Wheeling her in to do vot
via a wheelchair they were telling her
what to do cuz she didn't seem like she
really understand it's very sad the way
that this looks out almost bordering
elder abuse you know it's it's not aged
Tammy because you can look at Bernie
Sanders I mean that guy's older than Joe
Biden but he's still pretty sharp as
attack and he's he's got a very high
energy level Donald Trump exhibit B I
mean is a very high energy level and is
cognitively I I sat with him interviewed
him was supposed to be an hour ends up
being two hours um and on a wide range
of topics what what the question I have
here is the real reason was they didn't
want Gavin Nome who had promised to put
a minority uh in in her place if an
opening occurred there was politics in
play and people that wanted Adam Schiff
to get that job well Adam Schiff
according to Gavin new is not going to
be on that short list and I believe that
was a play Am I
Wrong well it's all politics this is a
political position Diane Feinstein was a
political woman really introduced to the
country after the murders in San
Francisco of mcone and and Harvey Milk
and she had to tell the city of San
Francisco about those assassinations
that's when she became mayor at a point
where everything was seemed to be
collapsing in San Francisco because of
that violence she also was the
conservative Democrat you know but
Californians used to you know elect a
women like Diane Feinstein and there's
few and far between now just really
moderate individuals I know there's
arguments and differences about how we
would approach things and we sit here as
quarterbacks and judge th those Dynamics
but she does as as uh uh Dr safire noted
has a tremendous history when it comes
to accomplishments but every single
position including and we can't dismiss
that she may have been involved D in the
choice to continue you know she had
interests in what the Senate was doing
uh she had a lot of power she had a lot
of sense of herself but like fedman or
Joe Biden and others is that you know
there we see some issues cognitively but
then there is some clarity at other
times the American people are going to
have to decide about what's appropriate
and what it is they're going to continue
to put up with but I I would say that
Feinstein her death is a loss uh for the
politics of this country for what the
Democrats used to uh be and what we need
now if people that can cross a bridge
where we have some things in common and
also shame on you said shame on the
Democrats I agree but shame on many of
the conservatives that I hear from on
social media when I said I worked on her
92 campaign uh when I was the president
of now in Los Angeles she's a lovely
this is
before this is before Tammy saw the
light just I want to remind everybody
thank you both hey Sean Hann here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else